xin jing code changé les codes disrupt
et on entend tellement ces formules
qu'on a l'impression qu'il s'agit de
formule magique et du code de la start
up nation mais arrêtons-nous deux
instants sur ces mots changé les codes
remettre en question l'ordre établi
finalement cette formule est
révolutionnaire mais qui suis-je pour
vous parler de révolution pour vous
parler de vos code a changé
vous vous dites peut-être que je suis
une entrepreneuse qui vient représenter
un produit innovant ou alors je suis une
militante écologiste qui vient remettre
en cause l'ordre
la structure du capitalisme ou alors
finalement je pourrai annoncer
énormément de profil puisque en fonction
des codes que vous avez en tête
vous avez aussi une image un fantasme de
la personne qui peut remettre en
question ses codes
je suis ici et professeur de français
quoi de moins révolutionnaire qu'un
professeur de français
généralement quand vous pensez preuve
vous pensez ça ou ça parfois ça et dans
le meilleur des cas ça peut-être le plus
révolutionnaire de tous pourtant je
maintiens ce que je vous ai dit au
départ le professeur de français et en
premier plan lorsqu'il s'agit de
révolution à temps c'est pas du tout ça
ni comme ça rien de magique ou d'illégal
dans ce que je vais vous dire je vais
vous parler de votre rapport à la langue
puisque le professeur de français que je
suis puisque le professeur de français
que je suis n'est pas un professeur de
dictionnaires effectivement ce serait
gardé être dans la transmission
uniquement si j'étais simplement dans la
perpétuation des règles de grammaire le
même code en commun donc oui je
transmets ce code
mais le transmettre c'est aussi
permettre de le modifier
la même manière qu'un professeur de
musique transmet par le solfège par
l'apprentissage de certaines règles des
codes rigides mais c'est aussi le
professeur de musique qui va vous
permettre de vous en libérer et de faire
des boeufs par la suite être un
professeur de français donnait ses
points de repères c'est permettre par la
suite de faire danser la langue et c'est
de cela dont il va être question vous
allez me dire même faire danser la
langue
en quoi est-ce révolutionnaire toujours
un argument d'autorité à ce moment là je
vais dégainer camus et cette fameuse
formule
mal nommer les choses c'est ajouter au
malheur de ce monde je pourrais rester
blottis sous la halle de camus ou
continuer en faisant ma propre
démonstration et c'est ce que je vais
vous faire puisqu'on va partir des
exemples que vous pouvez avoir en tête
lorsque vous fêtez le dictionnaire
lorsque vous regardez les mots nouveaux
vous pouvez faire le panorama de votre
époque
regardez en 2021 et en 2020 les mots qui
sont arrivés dans le dictionnaire ou en
nous avons je m'arrêter sur deux mots
seulement et vous allez comprendre le
mot féminicide et le mot anti spécisme
lorsque m
lorsque aymeric caron intitule son livre
anti spécisme peu de personnes savent ce
que signifie ce mot
excepté les milan et les militants vegan
ou les personne qui s'intéressait à
l'écologie
quelques mois plus tard quelques années
plus tard non seulement ce mot est
utilisé par des non spécialistes dans
des émissions de débats mais en plus il
s'est démocratisé et il est dans le
dictionnaire
autrement dit on peut observer la
progression d'une idée en observant la
progression des mots dans le débat
public et leur vulgarisation leur
démocratisation des mots apparaissent
des mots et disparaissent également ou
plutôt notre rapport à certaines
expressions
je vais donner l'exemple de et c'est là
que nous avons parlé de féminicide des
unes de journaux pendant longtemps
lorsqu'on parlait
de meurtre on pouvait lire crime
passionnel il tue sa femme par amour ou
encore il se suicide avec ses enfants
aujourd'hui et à juste titre ces titres
font réagir sur twitter par exemple
pourquoi le site les mots tuent des
oeufs a recensé toutes ces formules en
dénonçant ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
forme de romantisme à sion du meurtre
lorsqu'on dit il tue sa femme par amour
il ya un côté un petit peu romantique
plutôt que il la tue il l'assassinent
lorsqu'on dit il
il se ils se tuent avec ses enfants on
n'entend pas la même chose que si je
vous dis il tue ses enfants puis il se
suicide lorsqu'il se suicide avec ses
enfants on a l'impression que ces
enfants ne sont pas des sujets ils sont
simplement le prolongement de lui même
et le meurtre n'est pas complètement un
meurtre vous allez me dire tout ça est
très lointain on va pas à faire
attention à tous les maux si vous voulez
mais d'autres font attention aux mots
pour vous je vais vous donner l'exemple
un exemple très connu celui d'édouard
bernese vous le connaissez avec le
documentaire propaganda on voit comment
edward bernays zh le neveu de freud pour
faire fumer les femmes parce que c'était
ça la part de marché les femmes ne fumez
pas dans la rue c'était pas bien vue et
doit bernès va réfléchir au mot et va
changer l'opinion publique grâce à des
mots et grâce à des photos aussi mais
surtout une formule à la place de parler
de cigarettes
il va parler des torches de la liberté
et les journaux vont reprendre cette
périphrase les torches de la liberté
imaginez on n'est plus en train de fumer
on est en train d'exprimer sa liberté
absolue on est en train d'être des
sujets libres et ainsi il a réussi à
faire fumer les femmes
vous allez me dire mais c'est lointain
maintenant c'est plus la propagande
oui lui même a renommé on parle plus de
propagande on parle de relation les
relations publiques mais pourtant toutes
les publicités utilise heures regardez
récemment vous
romney dans le métro ou ailleurs où vous
promener dans la rue et vous voyez ces
énormes affiches qui font de la pub pour
le pari sportif et le but on voit bien
qui est la cible
la cible les jeunes hommes urbains en
utilisant le langage un langage de rue
un langage de quartier pour faire fumer
les femmes ou pour faire jouer les
jeunes
on utilise leurs codes donc nous voilà
nous individus face à nos maux à ces
mots compensée dans l'air et on se rend
compte que des communicants ou des
politiques vont les utiliser
moi ce que je vous propose c'est de vous
arrêter et de réfléchir avant de mettre
un mot dans votre bouche je prends
l'exemple du mot qui me désigne très
souvent pour me désigner
on va dire une enfants issus de
l'immigration enfants issus de
l'immigration je n'ai pas un père ou une
mère je suis issu de l'immigration je
suis un phénomène sociologique un
phénomène historique
bon pourquoi pas mais aux états unis on
ne dit pas enfants issus de
l'immigration on dit première génération
d'américains première génération
d'américains
vous voyez comment une formulation
change la perspective première
génération d'américains issus de
l'immigration
de quel côté se tourner notre regard
pour finir cette première partie où on
se demande pourquoi s'arrêter sur les
mots et les faits que ça produit est ce
que mon objectif c'est de vous dire il
faut une police du lexique une police de
la parole d attendre d monsieur non non
ne parlait pas comme ça pas du tout pour
moi c'est un peu comme manger un fruit
parce qu'on parle de déconstruction mais
des constructions c'est un peu compliqué
parlons du fruit
lorsqu'on mange un fruit qu'on veut le
mettre dans sa bouche on peut l'observer
le sentir sais pas si vous faites ça moi
je sens parfois et ensuite les
incorporer parce qu'il va devenir une
partie de nous de la même manière
lorsqu'on entend ces mots lorsqu'on dit
tips à la place de dire astuces
lorsqu'on
10 incivilités lorsque on observe
quelque chose qui ressemble à de la
délinquance
on peut se poser des questions tient
incivilités vivre ensemble tips tous ces
mots ne vont pas de soi
les choisir c'est faire un choix les
communicants et les politiques l'ont
très bien compris ils ont compris à tel
point que maintenant on utilise les
éléments de langage et tout ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la fausse monnaie
des mots un peu le canada dry ça a la
couleur des de ce que vous voulez
entendre mais ce n'est pas du tout ce
que vous voulez entendre on a parlé de
green washing maintenant c'est
l'utilisation des mots de l'écologie
mais finalement pour faire totalement
linverse derrière donc lorsque je vous
demande de vous arrêter sur les mots
c'est aussi non simplement avant de les
incorporer mais aussi pour voir et ce
qu'il ne s'agit pas de fausse monnaie
donc on s'arrête on réfléchit avant de
croquer les mots et parfois c'est le
deuxième fois on a une indigestion de
mou ces mots ne me conviennent pas
comment faire d'un point de vue
politique aimé césaire n'aimait pas
rejeter totalement l'insultent qui était
le mot
mais tel un boomerang il en a fait la
négritude
c'est à dire que changer le code c'est
parfois prendre des mots de ce code
qu'on aurait pu rejeter et l'inversé on
appelle ça l'inversion du stigmate on le
fait tous on peut le faire avec les mots
qui nous ont blessés les mots qui nous
ont tués dans notre enfance par exemple
une jeune youtube buzz comme gaël
prudence you qui était traitée de grosse
lorsqu'elle était petite raconte comment
la réconciliation avec son corps est
passé par la réconciliation avec les
mots
le jour où elle a réussi à dire grosse
et jolie et non pas joli mais grosse le
jour où elle a réussi à comprendre que
le beau gros ce pouvait être un bon mot
pour elle
au delà des mots les mots portent une
histoire les mots portent des
connotations les mots portent aussi
socialement quelque chose
annie ernaux dans la place a voulu
rendre hommage à une langue à la langue
de ses parents ses parents par les
français elle est française mais la
langue de ses parents parents
prolétaires parents kg et et d'un milieu
modeste dte des personnes qui n'avaient
pas droit de cité en littérature elle a
voulu que ces personnes là existent dans
ses oeuvres
et elle a donc utilisé un style qu'on a
qualifié au départ de nom style asnières
90 elle n'écrit pas en dire et
l'écriture de cartes postales qu'on
envoie quand on a 5 ans et en 5e et
qu'on parle de ses vacances et pourtant
c'est et volontaire elle est allée vers
une simplification et ensuite en italie
qu elle donnait à entendre la voix de
ses parents
la voix du peuple elle permet attendait
en littérature proust aussi faisait
résonner la voix du peuple maupassant
aussi mais quand proust le faisais
c'était sa bonne et elle le dit proust
faisait parler sa bonne moi je fais
parler ma mère ça change tout puisque
proust lorsqu'il donne à entendre une
voix
c'est avec le folklore regardez comme
ils parlent une forme de connivence avec
le lecteur bourgeois c'est ce que diagne
arnaud alors que elle lorsqu'elle fait
parler sa mère c'est pour faire résonner
une voie pour faire exister une voie
pour changer le code de la littérature
pour dire attention cette voie là aussi
a droit de cité en littérature et on
arrive justement à la littérature à la
littérature tels que vous l'entendez
uniquement avec des classiques mais la
littérature comme façon de penser la
langue autrement et de penser la langue
dans son rapport à trois choses
l'intraduisible à l'impossibilité et au
palimpseste
vous allez me dire qu'est ce que c'est
que ça je vous explique
en 2021 la langue qui domine on va me
dire ces langues
mais c'est pas en anglais ce que
l'anglais est vraiment une langue la
langue qui domine c'est le globish le
global english
et comme le dit très bien barbara cassin
l'académicienne et philosophe le globish
pose un problème non pas sans ce n'est
pas son existence qui pose un problème
mais si le globish remplace toutes les
langues
on perd quelque chose de très humain on
perd l'intraduisible je m'explique avec
le globice le but est de communiquer de
passer une information tout simplement
comme si les mots étaient des étiquettes
sur les choses alors qu'une langue dans
une langue on passe bien plus que ça il
ya la culture bien sûr mais il ya aussi
cette part d'un traduisible pourquoi
vous vous disputez vous parler la même
langue et vous allez vous disputer avec
votre copine avec votre enfant pour un
malentendu dans le global english le
malentendu serait une erreur a éliminé
mais dans notre langue humaine
le malentendu dit tout de nous si vous
vous disputez avec votre copine parce
qu'elle vous a dit tu n'es pas un homme
et que vous le mot homme c'est vraiment
ce que vous voulez être par dessus tout
parce que c'est une histoire familiale
vous voyez bien que les mots se creuse
d'autres choses et ça c'est l'image du
palimpseste dont parle jeunes est jeune
est par les départs ce départ chemin où
il y avait un texte ce texte avait été
effacé on réécrivait dessus et donc à un
moment il y avait votre propre écriture
mais en creux une autre écriture c'est
le palimpseste est la langue la langue
vivante notre langue profondément
humaine est toujours comme ça lorsque
j'utilise des mots lorsque vous entendez
ces mots il se creuse d'autres choses de
connotations de souvenirs de mythologie
le mot n'est pas seul le mot n'est pas
une étiquette et je vais finir sur cette
idée
accepter l'impossibilité dans la langue
l'intraduisible dans la langue le
palimpseste dans la langue c'est ça
disrupt et changer les codes puisque en
faisant cela vous donner accès à votre
sujet véritable vous vous arrêtez et
vous vous dites j'ai envie de parler
avec justesse moi mon ma métaphore la
métaphore que j'aimerais rajouter au
monde c'est la métaphore de
l'ornithorynque par exemple à la
question des enfants issus de
l'immigration aux premières générations
n'ont aucun d'eux me convient mais la
métaphore de l'ornithorynque me convient
je les ai inventées jeudi je suis un
ornithorynque voilà pourquoi
l'ornithorynque parce que leur nid
taurin qui pondent des oeufs et à l'aide
ses petits on a l'habitude de mettre
d'un côté les animaux qui pondent des
oeufs et de l'autre côté des animaux qui
allaitent leurs petits deux
classifications binaire c'est tout
l'ordi taurin qui arrivent et par son
existence même
il remet en cause les classifications
j'ai l'impression que ma métaphore de
l'ornithorynque peux vous parler
lorsqu'on vous demande de choisir et
vous trouvez que c'est un peu binaire
je suis un ornithorynque et pour
conclure tout c'est toute cette
prestation tout se tait dicks montée
dicks est dédié à un homme à 2 à 3 mm le
premier c'est alain rey alain rey qui
nous a quittés récemment et qui nous a
laissé le dictionnaire étymologique de
la langue française
formidable moyen de s'arrêter sur les
mots le deuxième mon père vous allez me
dire elle vient de faire un plaidoyer
pour la littérature et les mots et elle
vient dire son père ouvrier du sinn
marocain
pourtant mon père parlait par métaphore
parler par formule et je le remercie
parce qu'il faisait danser la langue et
enfin le dernier ce sont les professeurs
les psys tous ces passants qui vont vous
demander où même une personne sans abri
qui va vous sortir une citation qui va
inventer une métaphore et cette
métaphore va vous pousser à vous
interroger sur votre propre langue
et comme nous avons commencé avec lui
nous pouvons finir avec lui on est bien
sous son aile l'ale d'albert camus dans
l'homme révolté en 1955 il dit ceci la
logique du révolté et de s'efforcer au
langage clair pour ne pas épais cyr le
mensonge universel cette citation de
camus qui date de 1955 est encore
valable
les vrais classiques sont nos
contemporains et effectivement changer
le code c'est s'efforcer au langage
clair merci